ja also das sind halt so meine lkh
findet immer noch meine lieben freunde
und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge der sat wasteland wir
befinden uns gerade in der vordersten
überlegen fünften folge glaube ich ist
es ungefähr ja müsste doch zu sein und
zwar muss ich euch kurz sagen ihr hört
schon ich bin so gut wie jeder andere
youtuber zurzeit ich weiß nicht ob es
nur die youtuber sind oder allgemein
irgendwie jeder
ich bin total vom immunsystem einfach
übels im arsch weil keine ahnung ich
habe husten schnupfen muss bibliothekar
nehmen und alles möglich ist bei mir
einfach total schlimm deswegen kommen in
letzter zeit auch nicht so viele videos
außerdem dann noch gerade bei uns hier
fed krass erstmal so klausurphase und
alles ist nicht ganz so toll gerade hier
alles im moment klappt nicht so wie ich
mir das vorgestellt habe übrigens bin
ich jetzt gerade wenn ihr dieses video
seht in paris und macht gerade urlaub
und muss deswegen gerade im voraus
aufnehmen und muss dann quasi gerade auf
dem obwohl es mir gerade nicht so gut
geht
aber naja sind halt zu zeiten wo ich
gerade durch muss und ich würde sagen
wir konzentrieren uns eigentlich direkt
wieder hier auf das auf die desert
wasteland auf das desert wasteland wir
haben ja viele leute kommentare
geschrieben was ich dann besser machen
könnte zum beispiel dass sich dabei das
texture pack ändern soll
weil wir hier die ganzen in stansstad
sachen vom sand nicht unterscheiden kann
also ich weiß nicht ob der typ der das
gesagt hat eine augen hat oder irgendwie
einfach nur blöd dass ich mein guckt
euch den ständern und den stein also ich
finde da sieht man den unterschied aber
naja
lass mir außerdem gesagt wurde ist dass
das dort hinten ja eine dingen sei eine
wasserquelle und die sollte man finden
aber da haben dem auch andere leute
geantwortet achtet mal genau das ist
einfach nur dass die welt dann noch
nicht gerettet ist seht ihr dann bauen
sich jetzt zur prügel auf also ich bin
nämlich letztes mal irgendwann hier her
gelaufen und gefährlich dass wir zeigen
hier so ungefähr
dann hat man links am rand liegen diese
wasser gesehen da dachten alle dass der
wasser und dann nähe ist kein wasser und
na ja deswegen habe ich dann alles blöd
bezeichnet vielleicht es ja nicht
gesehen habe aber erstmal nachdenken und
dann hier schreiben und so und na ja ich
würde sagen das war's erst mal genug von
drum rum
ich kann ja mal ganz kurz sagen was ich
mich diese folge kümmern wollte und zwar
um die monster falle habe ich schon
gesagt ich weiß ich bin total verwirrt
aber ich habe nun eine entschuldigung
denn ich bin krank ich bin froh dass ich
noch nicht wussten falsch dass ich noch
nicht wussten musste jetzt während der
aufnahme und was auch leute zu mir
meinte naidoo kannst noch eine quelle
machen da du hast doch noch ein eisblock
wo habe ich denn bitte ein eisblock
ich meine ich habe kein eisblock ich
hatte nur ein ich muss das wasser
woanders finden und dabei welche du hast
doch lag also bitte erst bevor mir tipps
in die kommentar scheint erstmal
nachdenken und dann schreiben also dass
es ganz gut
wo ich dennoch da wollte ich noch
einpflanzen ich würde sagen wir setzen
uns an die monster falle so wie ich das
gesagt habe und dafür brauche ich
definitiv definitiv moment da was auch
jemand meint ab heute ist alles nur hier
eine folge wieder mit meinen und alle
also nicht meine seele von unter der
erde beinen sondern meinl im sinne von
eingemeindungen zur da meinten welche
ich kann ja doch verzaubert und soll
doch mal experience sammeln weil ich
lass mich einfach so ohne grund töten
weil ich denke ja level bringen eh nix
weil was bringt mir das wenn ich hier
keinen enchantment table machen kann
aber das stimmt ja gar nicht dass
kammern weil irgendwo hier unter der
erde soll angeblich ein diamond
versteckt sein und verein enchantment
table braucht man einen diamond
zuckerrohr haben wir und holz oder habe
zukaufen müssen wie die oase finden und
ich würde sagen die richtung sind wir
schon ganz gut gelaufen da hinten waren
wir erst recht schon
wir können einfach mal dahin laufen da
war ich noch gar nicht und erst mal
diese oase suchen weil bevor wir in dem
opfer anfangen können brauchen wir
definitiv besser also so wie ich mir die
vorstelle bin mir nicht sicher ob ich
das ganz richtig mache mit der mob falle
dann ich weiß nicht ob man die unter der
erde bauen muss aber ich mache das
einfach weil das ist für mich irgendwie
finde ich vertraute erwähnte falsche
ausdruck könnte sagen
realistischer bei der amokfahrt immer
noch nicht so gut verwenden
ich hab nicht mal hier ganz kurz runter
ist wurde mir auch in die kommentare
geschrieben
ja ich lese fleißig kommentare und nein
ihr braucht doch nicht schreiben zeigt
dass damit er das sieht wenn ich etwas
sehen will dann sehe ich das auch dass
an manchen stellen hat mir einer
geschrieben sind hier so witzige sachen
nach unten und dann gibt's da redstone
paar ärzte also wurde mir gesagt ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob man deren
vermutungen und gerüchten glauben kann
aber mal schauen
also ich bin schon relativ tief wäre ich
glaube dass nichts hinter moment war 36
sie einfach nicht ob wir gehen wir noch
zehn runter also ich denke nicht dass
hier etwas ist übrigens fragen mich auch
mal leute ja du warst ja immer spiele
ich bei dir so schwer und so alles
sauber wo bist du auf der schule was
machst du wenn du für lkw's und so
weiter sondern alle die es nicht wissen
wir noch nicht wissen können weil sie
ihm wie noch auf eine andere schule sind
bzw in der geringeren klasse sind als
ich sag ich mal
ich habe bei uns gibt es ist also ich
bin in der will dass der turm ich bin in
der oberstufe elfte klasse und noch
anderthalb jahre sei dann habe ich mein
abi das finde ich auch ganz gut wenn ich
das alles schaffen und ich glaube ich
bin falsch laufen einfach weiter
jedenfalls
mußmann lkw's wählen das sind
leistungskurse davon wird man 2 dann
wählt man vier abi fächer und dann das
das sieht interessant aus
dann wählt man auch da ist übrigens was
jedoch nicht guckt da dachte jetzt auch
schon eine wasserquelle einfach noch
nicht geregelt ag generiert
naja und dann wählt man halt auch noch
so da das ach das ist wahrscheinlich die
bürger dass die oase glaube ich dass
endlich auch im geiste wird sich
außerhalb leistungskurse von denen man
zwei wochenstunden mehr hat als von
grundkursen also gekas und anelka thema
die welt man halt wenn man die gut kann
und da habe ich deutsch und englisch
jetzt wahrscheinlich alle war arzt
fremdsprachen also deutsche setzen in
dieser fremdsprache
aber ja deutschen englisch weil ich
finde auch gott hätte ich mal einmal
mitgenommen dass es hier gewusst dass
hier eine quelle ist ach menno naja ein
fach deutsch und englisch weil deutsch
finde ich musste ich noch nie für lehren
also natürlich manchmal ein paar
struktur auf läufer oder so aber nicht
so viel wie für andere fächer wie
deutsch ich meine anderen fremdsprachen
muss sein wirklich vokabellernen alles
bei deutsch ist das nicht der fall da
finde ich schon ganz gut ich nehme
einfach mal so ein paar blöcke mit das
find ich halt ganz cool und bei englisch
finde ich einfach dazu fällt mir
irgendwie leicht also ich finde
englisch ist eigentlich recht somit das
einfachste fachforum besteht in den
dschungel baum somit das einfachste fach
was es gibt finde ich weil es ist quasi
ich bei mir ist es wirklich manchmal so
ich versuche also bei mir über das schon
öfter so dass ich ein wort auf deutsch
nicht wusste aber dann auf englisch und
ich weiß nicht woher das kommt also ich
war eine kurze zeit mein england aber
ich bin nicht sicher woher das kommt ich
nehme den setzling jetzt aber mal mit
the piece of me hobo
wir können hier etwas abhaken findet die
oase punkte melonen vortag des films
kaktus für mich verarschen mussten den
kaktus
na ja gut das wasser bis auf jeden fall
gleich irgendwie mitnehmen wir wissen ja
jetzt schon ungefähr wo das ist ja hier
ungefähr
ich glaube mich jetzt einmal hoch
irgendwie war das funktioniert ja also
das sind halt so meine lkh führt immer
noch
und was habe ich sonst noch so für
fächer ja keine ahnung jedenfalls
schreibe ich halten morgen auch eine
deutsch klausur und ich nehme gerade auf
anstatt zu lernen weil ich halt vor
produzieren muss für paris während ich
dort bin
und dann kann natürlich immer so die
fragen auf ja das kann ja alles gar
nicht so schwer sein
stört sie aber nur um wegen schule und
so ich kann ja mal warte ich hab ihr
buch liegen
ich kann immer ganz gut dass von mandy
einsatz vorlesen ist erst mal kurze
zwischen tastatur und bildschirm ich
hoffe mal das kann ich perfekter kann
ihr leben bei einer hot vorlesen ihr ich
lese mal ganz kurz nur ein bisschen weil
deswegen seid ja nicht hier um zu lernen
wir schreiben einen eine eine
textstellen analyse über iphigenie auf
tauris von johann wolfgang von goethe
johann wolfgang von goethe oder johann
von wolfgang und wieso kein
unglücklicher ich lese deine bande zum
zeichen einer schmerzlichen geschickt
die freiheit die das heiligtum gewährt
ist wie der letzte lichte lebens blick
des schwer erkrankten todesboten wurde
auf jegliche der schwer erkrankt
todesboten noch kann ich es mir und darf
mir nicht sagen dass ihr verloren seit
wie könnte ich euch mit mörderischer
hand dem tode weinen und niemand der sei
dass euer haupt solange ich priesterin
dianes berühren
doch verweigere ich jene pflicht wie
sieht der aufgebrachte könig fordert
blabla ich sterbe gerade da habt ihr ein
bisschen was gehört also das buch ist
echt sein deutscher sicht sage ich mal
was ich da ganz interessant daran finde
ist einfach dass ich überhaupt nichts
verstehe ich verstehe ja nur so einzelne
passagen und musste mir wirklich bei
wikipedia eine zusammenfassung von einem
deutschen buch dessen übersetzung von
einem deutschen buch auf deutsch an
gucken durchlesen und dat dat is echt
selten dass man ein deutsches buch
übersetzen muss weil goethe ist einfach
so was von komisch also der jet der
schreibt einfach so kuckuck
das schreibt einfach so richtig
altmodisch stolz so richtig irgendwie
witzig aber irgendwie finde ich total
komisch nur na ja ich würde sagen
jetzt können wir uns noch nicht machen
deswegen werden wir gleich mal schön
hausgemachte wir haben zwei wolle über
momente
das heißt wir werden jetzt glaube ich
mal rausgehen und so ein paar monster
hier klappen und danach und so eine
tolle farben bauen
nach ihrem tollen bogen können wir mal
einfach zack-zack perfekte klappt ja
sogar so wollen wir spinnen nennen ist
eine spende wartet das ist weit weg
übrigens dass die teile keinen körper
haben das ist halt einfach so beim tec
steckt mir gesagt konzept war scheiße
ich weiß nicht woran es liegt aber es
ist halt einfach so es muss so sein
ach ich war noch aus doch scheiße tut
mir leid dass ich dass sie nicht
abschätzen konnte aber ich war noch so
wir haben zurzeit ein privaten minecraft
server kann kurz erzählen
und dort ist es bei uns so dass ich da
ein also wir spielen da stand ich und
300 spielen einfach mal so just for fun
manchmal da ist es so dass ich halt ein
entspanntes gott jetzt ruckelt hier ein
enchanted schwert mit level 30 halt
enchanted und rüstungen alles habe und
ich musste wirklich nur einmal schlagen
oder zwei mal und zum office down und
deswegen war ich da ein bisschen noch
dran gewöhnt mal was essen haben wir
nicht weit also bietet nicht gewachsen
wie die jetzt im sinne von weizen
natürlich
belohnen schön aber auch wieder ein
bisschen hier holz gesammelt er holz
holz holz vor allem holz zwei strings
habe ich zwei wir brauchen noch zwei her
gut wo es eine spende spinne spende
spende spenden der spindel spende
darum ist ein krieg allein das ist
spinne
der fall so das vg köln bett motto wir
können im moment die brauche ich
natürlich auch noch die auch noch die
auch noch da war es lädt das auch noch
wunderschön einfache wir wollten das
wasserholen stimmt einmal was sie sonst
noch irgendwas brauchen wir noch
irgendwas eigentlich nicht obwohl ich
will das nicht wieder dahin laufen
sondern noch kurz was in der folge hier
schaffen und zwar könnten wie er da ja
theoretisch ihr einfach nur mal kurz was
dran bauen und dafür brauchen wir erde
ich hole ich beheben so wir wollten
allgemeinen die farben bisschen
erweitern was ich kann es schon mal
anfangen
das hing noch ungefähr
ja ich weiß sport wieder viel zu groß
aber ich finde einfach so eine farm die
muss ein bisschen größer sein weil ich
weiß ich könnte auch einfach ein wasser
fällt machen und dann darum alles bauen
aber ich finde das ist dann keine
richtige fahren wäre eine farbe muss
charakter haben
so ab geht's wasser trägt mich darum
sagt was so war es doch mal dahin war es
glaube ich da bin ich bin aber egal wir
brauchen keine rolle mehr gab es
irgendeine aufgabe crafted hier ein bett
verpiss dich alter kräfte wolle haben
wir doch schon längst wird haben wir
dennoch finde erde von zusätzlichen
orten
da haben wir haben wir jetzt auch schon
also diese wahl zweiter ort wo wir die
dinge gefunden haben haben wir denn
sonst noch den lohn farmen kay oppermann
punkt vormachen unendliche wasserquelle
werden wir auch jeden moment bauen
sichere weg punkte mache ich auch schon
mal kurz weg da können wir einfach mal
so lohnen die aufgabe zu erfüllen machen
wir das war eben irgendwie so